here welcome to this video plane and Ray
gassy and you know it's got the Chinese
flag so this is something for them for
the investigators because he got his key
got the Russian flag before and to know
with the Grand Prix tournament going on
in Beijing China maybe this is an
indication that is one of the Grand Prix
players okay well i played them um the
symmetrical english so this this liner
with Bishop f5 is interesting i only
recently I'm recognized that this is
this is even a possibility it leads to
interesting play okay i still need to I
need to retreat him
I managed to exchange the fianchetto
mission which usually am is quite
helpful ok he will play 95 I will castle
check yeah the question is um yeah f6 I
don't want to play f6 really hmm
what about a fire is this a booth
i'm not sure but i think i'm thinking
about f6 and night f72 to get this zone
to get the night yet back into play
maybe if maybe this is good yeah hmm
with 95 95 coming okay
yeah this is this is getting ugly deform
maybe I can irritate him a bit with the
smooth side then nitey six month I have
it's a bit ugly all this ok quindi three
yeah this could could be a terribly bad
but it also could could be good now
because it's the only move that prevents
deform now simple chess with Roxy three
I can go to e4 and after f3 or d3 the
queen is trapped
I can go to e2 though
maybe it gets trapped anyway
hmm young this is very very shaky
will be surprised if there's some some
direction tactical shot here and ok no
direct shot but also looks III mmm i can
go here
yeah you can I think just recapture with
the Jeep on and it's it's the same
problem again maybe here I'm d3 I can
capture yeah probably the queen is lost
in some way but I don't I don't see it
at the moment
i can i can drop back now ugly but the
queen I need to put it somewhere maybe
it's a sit still check it's still on
still playable 94th even hey 92 i think
i misplayed that I'm back in the game
okay I'm still I'm still in bad shape on
the clock but not sure that this
position is so awful
now g-49 have any time this is the main
problem
now the position is quite okay to say
the least I'm winning but 20 seconds
takes on f5 a check on you will in a
fine morning check check
check check check check
yeah I only managed to draw an endgame
out of this and turn eight seconds yeah
not sure if it is a check check a bit
more actor shia check check black why
you're on her black is completely
winning now but this is an increment
blitz yeah but I was certainly had I
simply had spent so much time trying to
not lose the Queen and he's probably had
some way to catch it but but didn't
manage and i'm not i'm not sure the comp
doesn't give like + 7 or saw the Queen
it seems couldn't be a couldn't be catch
that easy that easily okay I know this
is just just bad play marine Queen age 3
is Sir is CG item but this is also good
for black y'all need to get rid of this
night and okay this was of course
influenced Knight takes e4 is also
winning but this also wins can so here I
should probably just recap check but
okay it's a little time exam I wanted to
a simple position can Jackie down here
this I'm not sure but what's the best
tip I can take be five yeah it doesn't
matter i'm on to our second so we can
analyze it on all the time that you want
he simply relied on the fact that
spent too much time saving the Queen all
right thanks for watching